N
THIS VERY IMPORTANT STORY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO BOTH OF
YOU, WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>>> NOW TO A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT
IN THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION.
THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE MET
WITH TRUMP'S FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILLIAM BARR.
HERE IS COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
BENNIE THOMPSON EARLIER THIS
MORNING.
>> TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL ALREADY.
WE HAVE TALKED TO DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE INDIVIDUALS.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT OUR
MILITARY WAS PART OF THIS BIG
LIE ON PROMOTING THAT THE
ELECTION WAS FALSE.
SO IF YOU'RE USING THE MILITARY
TO POTENTIALLY SEIZE VOTING
MACHINES, EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
DISCUSSION, THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO
KNOW.
>> THAT LAST PART BASED ON A
DECEMBER 2020 DRAFT EXECUTIVE
ORDER FIRST REPORTED BY POLITICO
THAT WOULD HAVE HAD THE PENTAGON
SEIZE VOTING MACHINES.
A FRIGHTENING DETAIL THAT
APPEARS TO BE ONE PIECE OF A
HIGHLY ORCHESTRATED, MULTITIERED
COUP PLOT INVOLVING TRUMP
ALLIES.
NOW HOUSE INVESTIGATORS HAVE
THEIR HANDS ON HUNDREDS OF WHITE
HOUSE DOCUMENTS THAT TRUMP TRIED
TO KEEP SECRET.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT MORE WILL
COME TO LIGHT.
LET'S ASK SOMEBODY FROM THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE,
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN ZOE
LOFGREN OF CALIFORNIA.
CONGRESSWOMAN, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME, THANKS SO
MUCH AS ALWAYS.
HOW MANY TIMES DID THE COMMITTEE
SPEAK WITH FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR?
DID HE COME IN VOLUNTARILY?
AND DID HE DO MORE THAN I GUESS
OFFER MONO SYLLABIC RESPONSES TO
YOUR QUESTIONS?
>> LET ME JUST SAY IT WAS MORE
THAN ONCE.
AND IT WAS A VOLUNTARY
DISCUSSION WITH OUR STAFF
ATTORNEYS.
AND WE APPRECIATE HIS
WILLINGNESS TO HELP US FIND THE
TRUTH.
>> AND AS YOU KNOW,
CONGRESSWOMAN, BARR RESIGNED THE
SAME MONTH THAT THAT DRAFT ORDER
ON SEIZING VOING MACHINES AND
APPOINTING SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
OVERSEE THE ELECTION WAS
WRITTEN.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS AS A
COMMITTEE RULE, WE DON'T DISCUSS
INTERVIEWS UNLESS WE HAVE A VOTE
OF THE COMMITTEE TO RELEASE
INFORMATION.
SO I'M AFRAID I'M NOT ABLE TO GO
INTO ANY OF THE DETAILS.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY, WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT MEMO.
IT WAS NOT SENT, ISSUED, BUT IT
DOES SHOW A VERY WIDE RANGING
PLOT.
OF COURSE NOW WE ARE GETTING
WITH THE SUPREME COURT'S
OVERWHELMING DECISION, WE'RE
GETTING INFORMATION FROM THE
ARCHIVES THAT WILL HELP FILL IN
SOME OF THE BLANKS, SOME OF THE
MATERIAL, THE 700 PAGES WE GOT
LATE LAST WEEK, SOME OF IT IS
ROUTINE, SOME OF IT IS OF
GREATER INTEREST.
BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT WE
EXPECT TO GET IN THE COMING DAYS
AND WEEKS.
SO THIS IS VERY MUCH AN ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION.
>> AND CONGRESSWOMAN, LAST WEEK
WE LEARNED THAT YOU DID NOT GET
THOSE OUTTAKES, AS THEY'VE BEEN
DESCRIBED.
>> RIGHT.
>> FROM THAT JANUARY 6th VIDEO
WHERE TRUMP TOLD RIOTERS TO GO
HOME.
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT THESE
CLIPS CONTINUE TO EXIST AND
MIGHT THAT BE SENT OVER BY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES IN ONE OF
THESE UPCOMING TRANCHES OF
INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE HOPING
TO GET?
I MEAN, I SUPPOSE YOU SHOULD BE
GETTING ANOTHER DELIVERY, WHAT,
THIS WEEK?
IS THAT YOUR EXPECTATION?
>> YES.
YES, AND LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
WE KNOW THAT EVERYONE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS ADMONISHED BY
THEIR LEGAL STAFF THAT THEY HAD
TO TURN EVERYTHING OVER TO THE
ARCHIVES TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
SO IF THEY FOLLOWED THE LAW,
THOSE OUTTAKES WILL BE IN THE
POSSESSION OF THE ARCHIVES.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR THE OUTTAKES.
AND IF THEY EXIST, IF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION COMPLIED WITH THE
LAW, THEN WE WILL GET THEM.
AND WE THINK IT WILL PROVIDE
SOME INSIGHT INTO WHAT WAS GOING
ON THE DAY OF THE RIOT, WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S INTENTIONS WERE,
WHAT HIS STATE OF MIND WAS.
>> AND THE COMMITTEE IS NOW
ASKING IVANKA TRUMP TO
VOLUNTARILY COOPERATE.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT THIS MOVE IN A
CALL WITH "THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER," SAYING IT'S A VERY
UNFAIR SITUATION FOR MY
CHILDREN, IS THE WORD HE USED,
VERY, VERY UNFAIR, THEY'RE USING
THESE THINGS TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE'S MINDS OFF HOW
INCOMPETENTLY THIS COUNTRY IS
BEING RUN, THEY DON'T CARE, THEY
GO AFTER CHILDREN.
IVANKA TRUMP IS NOT A CHILD, HIS
CHILDREN ARE ADULTS NOW.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> FIRST, WE'RE NOT GOING AFTER
ANYBODY.
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR
INFORMATION.
NUMBER TWO, AS YOU POINTED OUT,
IVANKA TRUMP IS 40 YEARS OLD,
SHE IS NOT A CHILD.
AND THREE, THE REASON WHY WE
WANT TO TALK TO HER IS THAT SHE
WAS GIVEN A POSITION BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AS A SENIOR ADVISER.
SHE WAS THERE AND TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT ON THE DAY OF THE
RIOT.
WE UNDERSTAND FROM TESTIMONY OF
OTHERS SHE WAS ASKED TO CONVINCE
THE PRESIDENT TO CALL THE RIOT
OFF.
WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE SHE'S THE
DAUGHTER OF THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S BECAUSE SHE HAD AN OFFICIAL
ROLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT THE
PRESIDENT APPOINTED HER TO.
>> RIGHT.
AND THIS MORNING ON FOX, I
WANTED TO GET YOUR RESPONSE TO
THIS, THE FORMER HOUSE SPEAKER
NEWT GINGRICH SUGGESTED THAT YOU
AND EVERYONE ELSE ON THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE ARE CRIMINALS WHO
SHOULD BE PUT BEHIND BARS.
HE WAS SAYING THAT THE
REPUBLICANS WHEN THEY COME BACK
INTO CONGRESS SHOULD BE
THREATENING YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE WITH
JAIL TIME.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LITERALLY JUST RUNNING OVER THE
LAW, PURSUING INNOCENT PEOPLE,
CAUSING THEM TO SPEND THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
LEGAL FEES FOR NO JUSTIFICATION.
AND IT'S BASICALLY A LYNCH MOB.
I THINK WHEN YOU HAVE A
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS, THIS IS ALL
GOING TO COME CRASHING DOWN AND
THE WOLVES ARE GOING TO FIND OUT
THEY'RE NOW SHEEP AND THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO IN FACT ARE GOING
TO I THINK FACE A REAL RISK OF
JAIL FOR THE KIND OF LAWS
THEY'RE BREAKING.
>> WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT, CONGRESSWOMAN?
>> THAT'S JUST BIZARRE.
I THINK NEWT HAS REALLY LOST IT.
YOU KNOW, IT LEAVES ME
SPEECHLESS.
I MEAN, UNLESS HE IS ASSUMING
THAT THE GOVERNMENT DOES GET
OVERTHROWN AND THERE'S NO SYSTEM
OF JUSTICE, JUST RANDOM ARRESTS.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST A BIZARRE
STATEMENT.
AND HE LOOKS TERRIBLE.
>> AND IT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING
OUT OF AN AUTOCRATIC GOVERNMENT.
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE
ATTEMPTING TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION, SOMETHING THAT
WAS SUPPORTED BY MANY
REPUBLICANS UP ON CAPITOL HILL
IN THE DAYS FOLLOWING JANUARY
6th, THEY WANTED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT TOO.
UNFORTUNATELY THEIR TUNE HAS
CHANGED OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
AND MR. McCONNELL SAID THAT THE
PRESIDENT BORE RESPONSIBILITY,
SO DID THE REPUBLICAN LEADER IN
THE HOUSE, MR. McCARTHY, AND
MANY OTHERS.
WE ARE UNCOVERING A PLOT, IT
LOOKS LIKE, TO OVERTURN THE
PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER, TO
ESSENTIALLY OVERTURN OUR SYSTEM
OF GOVERNMENT.
I THINK THAT'S PRETTY SERIOUS.
AND I THINK MOST AMERICANS WOULD
AGREE.
WE'RE GOING TO DO OUR JOB
DESPITE BIZARRE THREATS SUCH AS
NEWT GINGRICH'S WEIRD COMMENTS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GET ALL THE
INFORMATION.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT KNOWN
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT WHAT
COULD BE CHANGED LEGISLATIVELY.
WE'RE A LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE.
WE'RE NOT GOING AFTER ANYBODY.
WE'RE GOING AFTER THE TRUTH.
AND IT WILL GIVE US SOME INSIGHT
INTO LAWS THAT SHOULD BE
CHANGED, PERHAPS, FOR EXAMPLE
THE ELECTORAL COUNT ACT THAT LIZ
CHENEY AND I ARE WORKING ON.
I PERSONALLY THINK THAT WE
SHOULD REVISIT THE ELEMENTS OF
THE INSURRECTION ACT THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT THREATENED TO
USE REPEATEDLY FOR NO REASON
THAT WAS LEGITIMATE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO TIGHTEN UP, TO
PROTECT OUR LAW AND ORDER
SOCIETY, AND TO AVOID THE KIND
OF CHAOS THAT WE SAW IN THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
>> MIGHT OTHER TRUMP CABINET
MEMBERS TESTIFY AS PART OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, MIGHT WE HEAR
ABOUT OTHER CABINET MEMBERS WHO
ARE COOPERATING WITH THIS
INVESTIGATION?
>> IT IS POSSIBLE.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY THAT AT THE
INVESTIGATIVE STAGE, YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY TELEGRAPH EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE ARE SOME
WITNESSES WHO, BASED ON THEIR
PRIOR CONDUCT, WE MIGHT WONDER
ABOUT THEIR VERACITY.
IF THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
ALREADY KNOW, I THINK IT MIGHT
ENCOURAGE THEM TO BE MORE HONEST
WITH THE COMMITTEE, BECAUSE IT
IS A FELONY TO LIE TO CONGRESS.
SO WE ARE IN THE INVESTIGATION
STAGE.
AND WHEN WE HAVE PUT THE ENTIRE
PICTURE TOGETHER, WE WILL BEGIN
REPORTING THAT OUT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.